[Music]
i'm still putting my makeup on because i
had a time management issue today so yes
during this uh introduction to the great
miranda cosgrove i will be applying
concealer in places you've never seen
concealer be applied where's that going
to be i mean i don't know if it's under
your eye we've seen it
i know i do concealer over my i do one
concealer where i
put it under and then i have another one
that i wipe and then another one that i
like pat it's a it's a tell us you have
tv trauma without telling us you have tv
trauma
it's like have you ever seen um
cupcake wars when they're icing that you
know they do want that you gotta do a
couple icings to get it
you got the caulk the grout and then you
have to have the thing that holds it all
is that how you think icing works
do you think you think they layer cock
and grout and then put anything on the
cupcake okay i'm so i'm bad at home
renovation cooking and applying makeup
and
modern does that show even come on
anymore i was trying to maybe they
nailed it
off that's what i was thinking or nailed
it our fellow you know nicole meyer our
girl yummy nominee nailed it yes yes
true true i want you to know that i'm
wearing a posture corset
and i've never had worse posture i'm
literally laying down it hurts so bad i
love it you look um
you have been going in and out energy
wise today there i feel i thought it was
maybe a low blood sugar thing it could
be yeah i didn't eat with the corset
i do like i do see that your feet are
holding you up just i mean it feels like
you have because my spine is so correct
you have to use it you're literally
leaned over you have to use your feet as
kickstand so in a couple months you just
wait
so this is to correct your it's just you
know we just we work in so many weird
situations i wanted something that's
going to keep me like this so like when
i drive here i don't want to like i just
i'm nervous okay slouching i already got
a lot going on i can't be slouching i
can't be the hunchback of notre dame
also oh no but where's the um uh uh i
have where are our posture correctors we
had posture correcting bras yeah you had
that posture backpack thing i have one
of those but i don't think it works as
good as this one i mean like it hurt it
hurts mm-hmm it's like a full course
and you develop muscles right in your
back and chest yeah i'm developing so
many muscles really quick you guys these
are this is marina costco's fan base
let's stop talking about our geriatric
issues here um so before we get to our
huge famous icon let's talk about some
random cities we'll be going to that you
probably don't live in where i'm gonna
peddle my yucks
we're gonna peddle some yucks
where are we going first we are one
month away from the kickoff of the touch
me stand up tour we're going to the
sunshine state how come i can never say
that sunshine state it's too positive
thick
uh anytime i think of sunshine i just
think of like i don't have a basal cell
is that a basal cell is that all
changing uh we're we're gonna go to the
cova capital of america
florida i say florida florida we're
going to florida we're going to be in
ponte vega september 10th we sold out
the first show we're doing a second show
at the ponte vedra concert hall and then
we'll be in clearwater
we're down to florida no we're not we're
not close to done because then we're
gonna go to clearwater september 11th
for two shows at the capitol theater
come see us before your state sinks into
the ocean i'm excited i love orange
juice yeah do you are you excited to go
to florida you've never been there yeah
that's where orange juice comes from
is that right
uh we're gonna follow up those cities
with uh miami it's in a miami that is
the one that is not sinking into the
ocean oklahoma miami
oklahoma we're going to be at the
buffalo run casino september 18th we're
gonna go to the route 66 vintage iron
motorcycle museum that seems like the
hot spot
who pulled that thin air i
did hey guys quick quick list of hobbies
motorcycles anyone no vintage iron
motorcycles
i don't know but my uncle got
decapitated on a motorcycle but i'll go
anyway
this the weekend after that we're going
to be in a place called sallowie a bispo
we're supposed to call it slow
which this open is
uh playing the fremont theater september
24th if you're a northern cal drive down
because sacramento is is sold out we
sold out the september fremont theater
vermont free
now we lock those doors baby bubblegum
alley is a place that we're going to
maybe be going bubbles that's my pussy
so you you told me about bubblegum alley
and i looked it up and i've never been
more angry by a photo
emily stormed off in a rage this is a
place where a bunch of people just go
put their used gum on a wall so i can't
think of a place i'd rather be white
people definitely thought of it in a
pandemic
for sure it's definitely where the delta
variant was developed because nobody
else in the world would be like you see
that thing that's not ruined watch this
let me put my spit on it
uh oh merch idea let me put my spit on
it
just a gentle reminder everyone blood is
not lubed boston we will be adding a
second show at the wilbur in boston on
october 2nd the 7 o'clock show and the 9
45 show are happening
i'm calling my friend who's from boston
hello
hey hello hey um we're just talking
about how i yeah it's my friend from
boston where can we get the best cream
pies where can we get the best cream
pies in boston
cream pies
that's a porn that's also a dessert no
it's not it's
pornhub.com is where you get the best
cream pies i could cover anything
anything ask me anything what about the
sale
you like lobster rolls you can go to
salem look at the witchcraft people
there's also
right but we're gonna be in boston what
about going to the front of the cheers
is that worth it the way they shot
cheers i mean
think about what you're saying i mean
that was not interesting when people
when cheers was a show
i'm actually quite upset again nothing
against them i mean everyone needs to
make a living but what do we do get some
baked beans i would get i would go down
to get to the lobster stop and get a
lobster roll okay where did what hotel
do we where do you try clamps i know
lobsters but um
down in quincy okay
it's a secret you go down there
it's a secret you mean it's a model yeah
make a difference
yeah i mean you think it could become a
thing like it could change the lives of
the guy that runs that place yeah if we
post some annoying content being like ew
clams to make a bunch of pussy jokes
maybe that yeah you could do that good
there's a good one on the north shore
that clam shack but this place this is
where my dad goes because it's cheap you
go down it's by the bridge in quincy all
right yeah for the lobster stop it's
next to the fireplace store in this
little strip mall there's a store that
only sells fireplaces so you suggested
going to a different place i texted you
the picture do you have covered
i
okay i have to talk about the rest of
the tour
well that was a segment that we call
unsubscribe from the good for you
podcast with whitney's friend nick
in richfield connecticut we added a show
at the richville playhouse on october
9th because there are only a few tickets
left for the first show on october 8th
they love us they really love us the
ridgeville playhouse is one of those um
one of the first thing that comes up
when you google ridgefield so i guess
there's nothing else
to do there except
what do you want to do there opiates
i'm doing two shows in atlanta at the
center stage theater on november 5th 7th
and 10 p.m royal oak we love you we
added a show at the royal oak music
theater uh the 17th of november because
we sold out the show november 18th
how about that
how about can i tell you something my
first ever feature set the first time i
ever featured was probably 15 years ago
at a venue in
um royal oak called the magic bag
no that's wrong okay the magic lies
right off the bat here's why there's a
venue called the comedy castle
that's where i did that but then there's
also a theater in detroit called the
magic bag which i have done i remixed
them
and the point is come see us at the only
sanely named venue in the detroit area
called the royal oak music and the point
is i'll be at neither of those places
but the point is i promise there will be
no magic and no
bags
i'm doing two shows on november 20th at
the pantages theater in minneapolis
minnesota 7 30 and 9 45 p.m hopefully
there's enough time between shows to
ride at least one of the roller coaster
rides inside the mall of america
and get that settlement i'm gonna get
that settlement the first show at the
neptune in seattle washington it's sold
out thanks seattle i want to go to the
graceland memorial hospital that's
grey's anatomy honey
you want to go do you think they really
shoot in seattle
no but that's where it's based out of oh
okay cheers that's where they have this
yes yes okay that's fair if you let me
go and they do shoot it there because
she lived there on purpose just for that
miss ellen peppa patoo
ellen pompeo my point is
fun show good times okay i'm not going
to that hospital is good i'm sure i'll
be there with some kind of miscarriage
but i don't want to go for the show we
added a second show at the vic in
chicago on december 11th because the
first one sold out so come on down at 10
p.m
however if you're the type of person
that goes to the top of sears tower and
leans on glass over the city please do
not come i do not trust you we're not
similar people
i won i can't do that i cannot do these
like giant thing like where you're on
glass and stepping on glass i just
cannot do it yeah i don't like hiding
it's not fun for me it makes me panic
not into it i think a lot of my
ancestors fell off as a former baby i
don't like heights yeah look as a former
baby there's a lot of things that we
have to walk on ourselves around
uh also in chicago oprah's headquarters
are there so if you guys want me to come
speak to your team and inspire them
you know where to find me and if we're
not currently scheduled to come to your
city you are in luck sweet pea because
we are announcing a whole slate of new
2020 dates in september i looked at the
confirmed list the other day and i
audibly gasped it is very many cities
that we were adding in 2022 that's right
we're going to denny's we're going to
shoney's we're going to ihops around the
world
and look i am doing probably at this
point 30
dates in 2021 i'm sorry 20 well i guess
we're doing about 30 in 2021 we just
added 20
for 2022
and you know what that means
i'm never having biological children so
i am literally giving up my chance to be
a mother without involving some
shady form of science in order to come
to your town entertain you so you better
show up just take the baby with you
you need to carry it for nine months
i can't even keep track of my fanny pack
when it's on my body well this won't cut
you're maybe gonna fall out of you on
the
road oh you mean this is the thing
this is the one time you'll be able to
keep track of the baby i need three naps
a day when i'm not pregnant
can you imagine me pregnant
yes i can how
well you would look like this but
pregnant and you'd probably be the exact
same so i think you should just get a
baby women are known for being exactly
the same when they get pregnant i think
women could do anything they choose oh
my god so what you should do is you
should get you should just come on get
your baby bring it with us who's gonna
okay
you'll hold it you'll carry it nine
months later you'll birth it uh-huh and
then you can relax
benton what would i do without you
i don't know how i guess just complain
about not having babies i would just i
would not be able to navigate i'm just
trying to come with the solution
okay which is get a surrogate emily's
available so
we're already starting the bargaining as
we speak because that would make your
life easier emily being pregnant
you can still text me 818239 7527 for
updates uh please do this so i don't
have to be so annoying with posting on
social media because it sends me into a
shame spiral so just text me so we can
all just
connect directly please
[Music]
i was re-watching last night the first
podcast we did together
and i
i know that you're one of the most
beautiful people that ever existed
but there's
something sickening
about how stunning you are
and i was like next time this bitch
comes on i am getting full pro hair and
makeup and now i look like you look
amazing i look like we're going to this
game like
parties we look like we're going to the
same like 90s theme party and we both
picked lisa loeb
and you're the bitch i would see the
party and be like that's what i was
doing we'd instantly become friends or
we'd instantly hate each other
because he'd be so embarrassed in the
corner being like we're the dorks that
chose the floral dresses with doc
martens though yeah that's true yeah i
feel like i i went more courtney love
uh and you went and went full lisa yeah
i agree i agree you say
did you know lisa like how old were you
when lisa love was happening um i know
who lisa lopez i don't know how old i
was yeah not sure because that was a
moment
that video where she was just like
storming up and down her apartment or
whatever it was i was like that's what i
do when i'm sad i need to watch this
video i haven't seen it you haven't seen
lisa loeb's stay no oh i gotta show it
to you because i do have a bunch of
pitches for icarly uh reboot season two
oh wow that's why i brought you here
today
too it's a dream come true
all my pitches so if you do anything
similar i can sue you for intellectual
property
it's a nice smart move no but i think it
would be cool if she recreated 90s music
videos
because we don't know what to do with
the web show portion of the show we've
been really struggling with it so i've
got it that's where i will i'm not a
writer producer on the show i'll be the
executive producer of the show within
the show i would love that
um
okay so
it is weird that after last podcast we
became
very good friends yeah we actually
became friends i was scared the last
time you were going to ask me um when i
was on if we were really friends because
you always ask everyone that i would say
i'll read here's what i always want to
let the guest
say to the audience what our
relationship is because i cannot and
then we can go from there and hopefully
it's somewhat honest because i can't
stand when i go on a show and someone's
like my good friend whitney cummings i'm
like bitch i don't know you
so now i have to act like we're buddies
and i don't know your son's name go
along with the life yeah i'd rather just
be like i don't know you that well this
is so weird that i'm gonna podcast and i
don't know you like and let's lean into
that awkward energy
you know what i'm saying yeah totally so
how where are we now i feel like we're
friends we're
very
to be fair it is mostly about pugs but
we do
animals because we have so much in
common like i do with the animals for
sure
not anything else well i think you're
cooler than me i mean it in a good way
like there's this you have this
rigmarole that you don't think you're
cool and i've had it
but i think you have an edginess and i
don't have like but that's not cool that
is it's mental illness it's not cool
it's sad
no you're i think that what
the way you comport yourself and think
and behave is cool
it's a little dorky but i think that's
cool okay thank you that's all it is
that is so cool that's the most punk
rock shit you can be right now dorky
he's like respectful and self-aware and
kind and funny but you're also
funny in a way
that kind of annoys me because it's like
it'll be like
okay well all right just steal the show
i mean you're like incredibly funny
thanks it pains me to say that i'm not
going to say one single funny thing
dude people like the reaction you on the
first podcast was like she's hilarious
and i'm like i know and they're like
miranda
i think it's just us together like you
bring out a funny side
you're like you're just fun to hang out
with you know what to say
that um warms my dead heart and
i during the pandemic i feel like i'm
very grateful
that your love life is a wreck because i
got to hang out with you for eight
months straight it's also such it's
crazy because the last time i was with
you i'm actually i'm jealous of you
because last week we were both talking
about being on raya and we were talking
about bad dating stories and stuff and
now
you're all happy and have someone and
i'm still exactly where i was when we
did the last podcast you know what's
crazy about the guy that i'm dating what
i tried really hard to set him up with
you
really yes no i was like well because we
met during the pandemic he was 30. he's
a critical care veterinarian who's also
like a sponsored professional rock
climber and he's just the nicest kindest
most honest funny
dreamboat and i don't i don't do
dreamboats i do narcissists and you know
guys that are secretly married and have
secret families like i was like i just
was like this is too healthy for me i'm
i'm gonna screw it up your vet is like
perfect for you i mean yeah and i and
here's the thing vets also can do some
human medical care
that was crazy he's given me a couple
ivs after some nasty hangovers and that
video you sent of your leg was was that
were you like numb yeah no
i mean i'm emotionally numb but not
physically and i had a crazy dog
fight situation happen in my home you
know when you have big fosters it
happens from time to time
you know they got confused there were
workers who cares always gonna defend a
violent dog um and
it was going after my girl my love of my
life uh ramona and so i just like i just
like stuck my hand in its mouth
and then another dog ran out to try to
defend me and then bit my leg and the
one time i wear a skirt wow so now it
looks way better it looks way better
yeah yeah doesn't it i got um
laser uh like scar removal laser and i
think what i'm gonna do i didn't know
this existed but it's kind of a life
hack i'm going to get my skin color
tattoo over it oh that's cool i didn't
know that that was possible i've lasered
i have a scar in my ankle from the
accident i got in on tour i told you
about the one where the driver's arm
snapped off yes i
i think i was in such shock when you
told this story that i didn't i didn't
know
how to process it because i was laughing
so hard uh because i laugh when things
are tragic and horrifying because that's
how i cope it's so inappropriate so i
try to set him up with you
that's insane so technically you're
saying i could be the one that's super
happy right now in a good relationship
you should be you could be the me
which my lover doesn't appreciate
because i i've tried to un subscribe and
log out but my profile's still up
people will tell me like hey just so you
and ryan i'm like i logged out of that
shit okay here we go see my right that
happens to a lot of people like they get
off it completely but they're their
photos still pops up okay i'm still on
it i don't even need you yeah although i
would like to look at your dms
login
one in here i'm sorry
hold on well first of all what's your
song cause raya is a dating app where
you have to pick a song you have to pick
a couple photos to do a montage and then
you have to have a song so for example
this will get us demonetized fine who
cares drew's song is
oh take one over the line
swipe left
like that i think that was the music uh
this man was listening to while he
stormed the capitol
so no thanks
okay so this is what happens i'm just
blowing up this person's spot
uh it'll play like a montage how do i
get over again how did i get out of here
who have you matched with recently don't
say names but what kind of let me see
them these are like the oh
miranda cosgrove just gave me her phone
with her dating app dms
holy shit
i
okay okay
as one of my favorite people on the
planet that i i can't wait to grow old
with if it's if you're capable of
growing old uh the fact that you had the
audacity to do a
episode of the new icarly accusing
someone else of being a robot was was
audacious i was like says the person
that looks like she's made out of
beeswax and caramel
um
so
evan
texted miranda on march 2020
at 4 14 p.m red flag doesn't have a job
or is texting from his job howdy there
miranda how's it going smiley face and
then wrote cute smile that was on march
1st
no response
and then i've given up on the app for a
while that's why i haven't answered and
then he writes uh march 22nd 20 days
later at 12 16 pm uh unemployed
so what apocalypse skills do you have
looking to gather a team for the end of
the world
boom
you wouldn't answer
and then evan evan writes that and then
uh in july
okay i'm sorry that was march 20th july
13th at 6 20 p.m
miranda right he got a job
no this is you oh no don't read what i
said i don't want any responses
hi
dude
why are you respo okay okay a very
famous successful
gorgeous incredibly talented actor that
has starred in many movies that have won
oscars
messaged you on july 3rd
at 9 17 a.m job job
and i'm learning so much i've not
responded
i can't say who the person is but do you
know who that is do you know who you're
ignoring do you know who you're ghosting
right now i don't like i hardly
i need to really go through and like
fight we're doing it we're doing we're
doing it we're gonna find a i have a
whole document written up about for this
podcast because i have so many questions
that i need to ask you that the fan sent
that emily's niece sent that
grace's roommate sent that's so nice
who's this guy hey miranda what's up you
look really pretty in your pics yeah no
shit
yeah it's miranda cosgrove can i respond
to these people
i'd be so funny do you live in la
what do you think
does a famous actress
in hollywood live in hollywood or are
they beautiful by any chance yeah thanks
so much
i feel like if you ran my dating life
i'd have like a relationship then
everything would be going this is a
psycho line august 30th luke writes
listen just promise me that when we get
married you won't tell people we met on
raya
what do you think
it's kind of nice
but this guy let's see what kind of guy
he's cute he just seems dorky to me and
dorky is a good thing
there was a guy that had a picture of
when he was little with all his badges
from boy scouts
it was kind of cute no
kevin spacey swiped right
uh and then he wrote your face almost a
year later
this first message was august 2020
second one april 2021 this offer still
stands in case you were wondering
i'm writing back
oh my god i'm sorry what are you guys
saying this i'm a famous actress that's
very busy
do you live in l.a
if so where
uh what else what are your red flags
um i don't know taller than you you want
me to can i ask his height what is your
what is your height and credit score
that'd be nice if they were like over
five nine
and if it's meant to be he will be fine
with the fact that he thought this
message came from you and he was cool
about it and later you were like
actually my crazy friend wrote that and
you'll like bond over it and then i'll
officiate your wedding we'll get married
yeah see i'm ready for that oh this is
not good
the number this is many messages many
months apart ari wrote what did you do
all weekend tell me everything also can
we please go on a fun adventure slash
date this week
two months later thoughts
eight months later uh hand over face
march okay that was february and then
march should we try this again
should i try back tonight nope oh my god
don't say that okay sorry if you're just
like yeah the lack of a response let's
do a response oh miguel wrote happy taco
tuesday what are you up to what's nice
nerd alert uh taco tuesday i love tacos
alec
what's the first thing you can't wait to
do once quarantine is over should i just
write back fuck
all these people are just going to be
out there thinking of completely like
then he wrote later how come i just
know realized icarly is on netflix
can we can i tell you can't sorry you
know that i can't not
make a business out of everything can we
do screen grabs of the ones that mention
your show and use them as billboards to
try to get more viewers that's actually
yeah it's like no it's a good like a
screen grab of this and we'll put a
different photo of a different guy and
then how come i just realized that i
carlos on netflix these are messages
messages from uh carly's dating apps
that'd actually be a really cute way to
publicize the show
you're onto something except you can't
take a screen grab of anything on raya
you have to do it on another phone or
you'll get kicked off yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah we'll get past that oh you getting
kicked off here would be a
such a tragedy
uh evan
oh my god what's the little pup's name
hey miranda how's your week going those
are inverted
these apps are stupid so i promise to
make this interesting and funny at the
very least lol don't lol at your own
mediocre
joke that wasn't even a joke it was a
sentence what do you think is like the
perfect thing to say to somebody as the
first the guy opened yes it was the guy
i think
like just hi hey there's no
cool way to do this
and just wanted to say hi and you're a
comedian so i'm not gonna try to be
funny
i'm just gonna say hey
here's my number so we cannot be texting
on a silly app text me if you would like
to
i've never gotten one like that that
sounds good yeah and for you it should
just be like hi
uh i know you're famous
these guys are trying to act like you're
not famous and then when you don't
respond then they go like oh i know
icarly like like as if you're such a
malignant narcissist you're like i'll
respond to you if you mention my no
that's way bigger of a red flag but i do
think they have to acknowledge it like
hey
i hope this isn't creepy or weird
because you're famous and you're on a
dating app but here's my number if you
ever want to chat like look at my
profile and if you want to know more
here's my cell phone number don't keep
texting me on this chinese app that's
stealing our data because you're famous
jim saying yeah that'd be good just to
be like super straightforward okay
you're getting lots of instagram updates
you never know what to say who's this
person i'm just looking for my exes on
here hey miranda do you like the show
big mouth that's the most sexual
opening
what if you're like yes he's like well
let me see your big mouth
happy thanksgiving miranda thankfully
you can match more than once on here lol
what does that mean oh you guys have
matched multiple times people expire
after a certain amount of time
again
jared
has another man's arm around him in the
photo there are couples on here that
come on and are like do you want to be
like our third let me find it first
okay let me
that's so weird because i was confused
because someone came up and they had a
girlfriend like all the pictures are
them having fun and doing fun stuff
together and then
he was messaging me you know
looking for a unicorn
no i don't want to be a part of your
fights and your breakup no i don't want
to come break a couple up i'm good
just break up
my thing is like just break up
if people are looking for a third i'm
gonna start matching with them on
purpose and i'm gonna go to their house
and they think it's gonna be like a
sexual we're about to have our three so
i'm gonna go hey guys i think you should
just break up and stop putting other
people through this like you're secretly
just sticking yes stop stop harassing
people and bringing other people into
your fake open relationship and just
break up
just call it
bye and then i would leave you'd be like
and you need to validate my parking
oh face id my face id shockingly did not
open your phone
how tragic
jesus okay okay a couple more
dane not cook don't panic oh no
this guy is in a
picture with a girl hold on
what's his uh oh he's a co-founder and
vp creative of fucking what
of what
don't do that don't try to use i'm a
co-founder i'm an executive producer of
what
i'm a producer of what
corn some people just don't need
anything at all like they have no thing
they have no bio and then it's like
actually
oh wait it's like what's that
wait
oh i don't know is that a girlfriend
wait so see he has a beautiful
girlfriend um i did respond to luke
let's see does it say red if they've
read it no it doesn't no it doesn't tell
you i don't think oh my wow your cat's
face
i do have a lot of pictures of my cat on
my raya profile so talk to me about um
i've been told that you have a
uh
a system every night where you in order
to get your cats back in you
offerings give them offerings yes i have
three indoor outdoor cats because two of
them are like practically feral and
they'll only let me pet them
so i can't like if i bring them in the
house they lose their minds and go
insane if i tried to pet it it would
bite or they just would run they
wouldn't let you if you cornered them
they might bite larry's bitten
someone but um he's mad because you name
him larry he looks like a larry like
you've never seen a cat that looks more
like a larry in your entire life
um but he so in order to get them in i i
buy like these little chicken
like tiny pieces of chicken from
petsmart they come in like a little
i don't know little thingy and basically
um every single night i it takes me
about an hour to two hours to
get them in
an hour to two hours when would you have
the time to date in between feeding uh
cats that could just eat mice it's
because i'm so scared that a coyote is
going to eat one of them at night so
once it gets started
to get them in that's it have you what
about the um not today coyote vest oh
i've seen one of those before it's like
it has spikes and snakes yes it has
spikes on it they have them for their
hats too they should totally put dude
in a spiky ass s m vest will be sick
it's called not today coyote and they
i'm sure there's other brands but i like
them the best and they make these like
spiky vests yeah i totally need one of
those i didn't know they made them for
cats though i thought they only made
them for dogs i mean i feel like even if
it is for i feel like they're
interchangeable in a way i mean they
have the same general torso i don't know
if larry would be psyched about this but
yeah you can get them they're super they
make them into little porcupines
basically and isn't it true that dogs
when they have problems with like having
seizures and stuff they wear vests
because it makes them or or no is it
when lightning is going off and scares
them oh yeah yeah it calms them down
like any kind of like like the same way
like a hug or any kind of like pressure
or a weighted blanket or a vest
essentially um activates your
parasympathetic nervous system so it
stops adrenaline i wonder if that works
like that too or maybe not you don't
want a dog to have less adrenaline when
a coyote is attacking them i want them
to be super crazy yes no we want them to
be very panicked and stressed out this
is larry larry but doesn't he look so
much like a woman that's not normal
what is this cat
i've nev this cat
is so scary it's like danny devito
i've now who would voice you this cat in
the mood i'm obsessed with this is how
when i'm getting foster dog homes which
you do spend a lot of time doing the way
i describe their personality is i'll
always say this is who would voice them
in an animated movie about such a good
way who would voice larry
danny devito was a good kind of girl
it's kind of perfect it's but it is a
little will fairly like a will ferrell
character like um like remember uh
ashley schaefer the character of ashley
schaefer on eastbound and down like it
could have a little bit of that like a
little bit of like a used car salesman
buyer like have you seen honey i shrunk
the kids like the lead guy i sort of
feel like he could maybe be larry's
voice i don't know well do you have any
other ones would you have the other any
other pictures yeah but who okay so
danny devito let's cast your cats danny
devito
larry is danny devito i feel like it'd
be funny if i mean he's crossed over but
if it was um like james gandolfini this
is more larry oh my gosh this cat
he has a really weird look right
yes this cat is insane looking
this cat no no coyote is going to fuck
with this cat actually i think never
mind he's doing amazing i don't think
he's so white and clean he's very
intense
yeah everybody describes larry as
intense maybe like kevin hart or
something oh that could be good yeah
isn't he the voice of the little um
the little bunny and uh pets oh i don't
know like he isn't he would do that
that's your world perfect
i don't know yeah that that would be
good or maybe like bill burr
or like a committee like tom segura or
something just joe rogan
uh
that's that's
amazing so if you were trying to get
someone to adopt that
cat
you would say i call it's funny because
i call him laird in every single night i
go into the backyard and i have to go
larry to get him to come in
like i have to do it a certain way
that is so
funny so i have a dog named daisy but
when no one's around i only call her
doo-doo and i go
it's like and she loves it i would i
would never do it around anyone but then
i have like workers in my house right
now and i i can't get her to come and i
have to be
like it's so i'm like daisy she has no
idea what her name is she thinks that's
her name that's so funny that you have
larry with an intonation specific call
and then it's really bad what is it
larry
my whole neighborhood hates it like
everybody in the area hears me every
night calling him in
i hate it like too when i accidentally
don't do it to like nine or ten at night
and then like if i get home late to get
him in
then the whole neighborhood has to
listen to me screaming his name
see this is a problem when you bring
guys home
when 10 o'clock rolls around when it's
about to be frisky time
literally out figuratively you're like
wait wait what is it larry
do you know that at disneyland every
night they let out a hundred and twenty
cats to go oh yeah they killed the mice
and it's so weird that a mouse is the
man i know i can't because i killed mice
at disneyland that's a little dark but
yeah it's like there's a lot of mouse
mice at disneyland i wonder if i could
get larry into the program at disneyland
and then i wouldn't have to this
wouldn't be my life anymore why did we
get larry to become one of the
disneyland cats he actually got an offer
once to go be a rat catcher in like
canoga park or something but then i
didn't let him go because they said they
didn't actually they feed the cats but
they don't give them like medical
attention if they think how were you
contacted about this
is this a next-door app situation oh my
god i found a dog on the next door app
on fourth of july i mean i saw someone
post on the next door app that they
found a dog and we're gonna take it to
the shelter the next day and i have him
right now
um i was like i'll take him don't take
him to the shelter so this lady brought
him to me
and he's like 95 years old she told me
he was like young like not an older dog
and he's like he has no teeth and he was
just
roaming the streets i guess on 4th of
july because you know how a lot of dogs
get out and they go running yeah but
this one's deaf so what and this dog
can't run or hear here
so there's a different uh the story is
very different than there's a different
list
this is much bleaker i mean the fact
that a coyote didn't even want to eat
them i was like what is that just like i
don't want that he has a bald spot
what's his name i named him taco because
he wouldn't eat for four days and then i
was eating a taco and he
ate some of it
he's really cute taco yeah okay
but it's so funny all like i can't get
him to eat and it's like the offerings
with the cats i spend all my time trying
to get this little dog to eat stuff has
he been to a vet yeah he had an ear
infection and they were like he's
probably about
15. oh my god he's really cute he moves
real slow taco buddy
he's super cute and my other dog
accepted him so
um the pug yeah the pug's like what's
the pug's name her name's mod mod but
because harold was adopted yeah harold
got a home was she okay she was so happy
that he was gone
i've never seen i've never seen a dog
happier in my life because it took me
like six months to give harold to he got
this really good family but i felt bad
splitting him up because i found him
together and um
yeah she was it's like her whole
personality came out one she was like
the doctor what is this motherfucker
dude this motherfucker is dead weight
she's so poor who would uh voice mod in
an animated movie about mine oh
she's like a little hell is she she
seems like an older kind of jelly
she seems like she's like oh she's angry
at me
i am tech avail all she cares about is
food um she has bad back legs and she
wakes up
she would do doesn't she need your name
judy judy dench could be funny julie
andrews but she seems too classy oh yeah
no but i did
her story about how julie andrews when
she poses for photos with people
uh when you pose with her she goes
money
no way because
the the face that her um
the expression on her face is the most
photogenic when she says the word money
money
but i'm like i don't feel like it works
it could be bunny or sonny or it could
be many other words why money
so when people post she just goes money
i thought you were gonna say because
it's like she's the money shot like she
know like she thinks she's really
awesome so she's like that would
make more sense to me than this someone
told like some publicist from the 40s
told her like to save money you just
gotta smile and say money
and whatever and she just has done it
this whole time i'm gonna start saying
larry when i go ahead and take a picture
it brings out the best in me guys
miranda
um okay so obsessed with this obsessed
with getting your cats into the i feel
like we can do it get into the disney
to have a celebrity cat at disney that
would be amazing i'd love it if they'd
take all my cousins and then i could
just the three because they're like
they're they're feral but right but i
want them to have good lives so i'm just
i am constantly having to do stuff for
them like every single night i have to
be home at a certain time in order to
get them in mm-hmm this is another
reason why it's probably good i'm not
interested i mean literally when
someone's like i'd love to take you
today you're like great i'm available
from four but i have a heart out at 7
15. that's when the coyotes come out
i i got the coyotes come out the cats
need me
man they don't like me or come when i
call them like you're not a cat person
we actually have to stop by vaughn's and
get a bunch of chicken on the way home
you can help me i'm not a cat person i
truly just don't understand what they
value
and therefore i just get very confused
and and they're like horses and that
they're very sensitive and they have
very different personalities there's no
such thing as one cat they're not all
the same at all one does not apply to
all right so it's like i think most of
the cats that i've been around probably
have been more aloof and i'm too
insecure and i'm like wanted to like me
and i'm like this isn't healthy like you
have to pretend you're not interested
for them to come over i'm like a dog you
can be so nice i don't know how to do
that i don't know how to like act around
the cat i don't want to be acting around
they make you uncomfortable i'm not
going to pretend i don't think you're
cute so that you'll like me i do that
all day
you don't to have to do that with your
legs
you know what i'm saying i've done that
on dating apps for the past 20 years
like i don't want to pretend i don't
like you you're i picked you because
you're the cutest one
and i love you and that's why i'm paying
for your vet bills i'm not gonna then
pretend like i don't really care that
much like i care a lot i love you dogs
are good for that yes dogs
you can never give them too much love
you know they don't punish you for
loving them yeah dogs are the greatest
okay i don't want uh your fans listening
or anyone to be annoyed that we're only
talking about cats and dogs all the time
because this is what happens when we're
not on camera so we're now just
essentially being private
yeah everyone's like can we please get
to the questions we sent in okay i'm
throwing you some questions these are
from grace's roommates
they're obsessed with you uh num the
number one question i've got for you and
i actually would like to ask this what
is your skin care routine my skincare
routine is actually so bad i um
now you're just making me annoyed i
started a skincare routine a little bit
because you said you always put
different oils and stuff on your face
because i had never used any oil really
on my face before right and i feel like
it really works yes yes it does i have
dry skin so yes it just it feels good
and it totally helped me and and oil is
actually also good for oily skin i know
it sounds counterintuitive you think
you're gonna break out whatever and you
might a little bit in the beginning but
i had really oily skin cystic acne was
on accutane twice um putting oil on
every night what basically happens is
your oil glands stop producing as much
oil because you're applying the oil so
you stop getting those cystic sits at
the root oh so oil is even good for oily
skin that's crazy i didn't even know
that i just my nose gets really dry and
my and i always break out on my forehead
so sometimes i'll just walk from your
hair i don't know maybe it's just always
happening i'm going don't
probably yeah
that's what it's from just feeding my
head but i am really bad at like
sometimes i'll wear my makeup to sleep
and i won't take it off
until the next morning
i mean that is wild i know it's really
really so you spend two hours trying to
feed feral cats but make no time to wash
your face
i mean i usually do but yeah you know
what you can do and what i do a lot
there's a couple like i think they're
kind of called like melts there's one by
eve loam and there's one by colleen
rothschild i'm sure there's other good
ones too i do
this i don't want to get into this
because mila kunis and ashlyn kutcher
and kristen bell and dax just did all
these interviews where they said they
don't shower that's not that's all i'm
saying
i will sometimes put oil on my face and
just use a um
washcloth to just kind of wash it and
not have water like oh because is it
because the water is really drying or
something well i do i really the key to
good skin is
keeping it moisturized at all times and
having it wet as as infrequently as
possible so even when i'm in the shower
i'll wash my face but i have grapeseed
oil right there and i'll put it on right
afterwards like i don't get out you
don't get out of the shower and wait 20
minutes to put your cream i'm going to
put on sunscreen that's the one thing i
do what kind
um i use all different ones i like oh
tatcha have you ever oh yeah i love that
brand tatcha has oh i'm mixing that up
with um
there's a sunscreen that's a gel that's
by julep j u j-u-l-e-p
i think it's called no excuses and it's
like a light gel
that you don't like feel like you know
like it's almost like i don't like
putting a bunch of sunscreen on and then
it all sweats off and i'm like is it
still on is it not yeah i love and i
think there's a drunk elephant a good
sunscreen yeah great they have great
stuff but i've been using all tatcha
products lately and i like them a lot
like they i just like the packaging too
it's really cute hashtag paid
partnership with the top chat i'm not
trying to sell tatcha i swear but um
on my hair and i found out the other day
you're not supposed to do that it's
really bad whatever you're doing
keep doing it
where did you find this out read it
people everybody i tell that i use a ton
of conditioner they're like no no like
you're supposed to use like uh you're
telling about
you're using a bunch of hay-headed
bitches
for your hair advice when you have
easily the most beautiful hair
on television oh my god i'm going gray i
found out a couple days ago where i
don't know in the back let me see
somebody said is it true somebody told
me i'm going gray in the back
you have a lot of people around you
trying to sabotage you
tell me the truth because people won't
i've been trying to get a straight
answer from people for a while and i
feel like nobody will be honest i will
be
hold on who what what jealousy
hey fucking
bitch tried to tell you had gray hair
when i if i saw one i've been wanting to
ask you ever since it happened because i
felt like you'd be straightforward
there's nothing i want more than you to
have gray hair
uh i definitely have some gray hair have
you ever plucked a gray hair out your
hair is of course i have what are you
loco your hair
feels like um
oh my god it feels like
like uh
what is that it's velvety
it's a
velvet i mean you it's i've never felt
anything like it
i do not see one gray hair thank you
this is no no don't thank me i swear i
swear that they're not right
hold on it was like around this area
where the no i would have found it i
live to find gray hair in young women
it's the only thing that gets me through
today
i seriously did the person pluck it no
when you put it on ebay
if i find it i will be selling it when
do most people get gray hair like around
like it depends it's usually genetic oh
you look insane
hold on give me one second
i'm just gonna brush my hair i'm like
who are these bitches sabotaging you you
just look like certified thank you
silkiest the silkiest hair my hair when
it gets to here it gets split in half
like split out oh no i have split ends
no you don't
your your hair is so silky
it's sickening it's like feels like what
is um
uh like a jellyfish it feels like a
jelly jellyfish yeah it feels like you
know when you go see um
uh one of those things not manta rays
stingrays and you get to touch a
stingray at an aquarium that's what that
feels like i feel like everyone's going
to want to come on your show just to get
like
just just feel good about themselves
afterwards no this is like the highest
my confidence has ever leave here
feeling amazing feeling awful most of
the time
we now interrupt our interview with me
and my daughter miranda cosgrove to talk
about one of my favorite sponsors
stitch fix emily finally get finally
listened to me
i've been talking about stitch fix it's
changed my life and then emily finally
got in her that thick skull of hers
last time she packed for her trip yeah
here take a look okay
all right packing time how do i decide
uh
that was for my french mime look not
really feeling that that was my
hamburglar look that was my boy in the
story pajamas probably not the best
occasion for that oh this was my fancy
okay this was summer
i don't know i just feel like i need
something
new
oh i never opened my stitch fix box
let's see if they
are really great as everyone says i
don't know i don't trust
i love it stitch fix an online personal
styling service i am a convert wow that
was touching they really get me they
know that i'm in a stage in my life
where i want to keep it classic but also
want way more attention stat stitch fix
for you you can try on pieces at home
before you buy keep what you love and
return what you don't stitch fix has
free shipping easy returns and exchanges
and a prepaid return envelope is
included not that i would return that
you loved it stitch fix has styles and
clothing that fit any occasion for women
men and kids and they ship all over the
us and they're available in the uk as
well
since working with stitch fix and
getting some more adult mature pieces in
my closet i'm finding that people in
business meetings have stopped asking me
if i'm okay
it's very nice to go through life and
not have people doing interventions on
me all the time you know worried about
me so thank you stitch fix for some
appropriate fun tops that make people
want to hire me get started today at
stitchfix.com
whitney and you'll get 25 off when you
get everything and keep everything in
your fix that's stitchfix.com whitney
stop mocking me emily for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
i mean we know you need a lot of
attention with the striped shirt but
this is really pushing it stitchfix.com
emily
whitney
stitchmix.com
benton did you know we were going to
have a special visitor huh no but i can
smell jules as you may have noticed from
our podcast we have outstanding guests
people are banging down the door to be a
guest on our podcast and people are also
banging down the door to get me pregnant
we have a very special guest here to
talk to us about a new birth control
subscription service called pill club
is it octomom a duggar no please the
queen of england
there is many adjuster will want to give
you
the royal scepter
but not every queen has time for a royal
baby
why your majesty is a firm believer that
bending the knee is the most fun form of
birth control
is not enough
which is why i recommend peel club to
all my ladies in waiting
with the pill club you'll be treated
like well well me
you'll never have to make a trip to the
doctor or wait in line at the pharmacy
ever again
they provide access to care from comfort
of your home
and delivery to your door in discrete
packaging so as not to start a royal
scandal
we've been through enough these past few
years with that girl
from dill or new dill
the bill club is a birth control
subscription
prescribed by a medical professional
and delivered straight to your door for
free
hmm so through your crown
take off your bloomers and have fun
while confidently knowing you will not
create an unwanted
air
you know
oh
know what bitch
the pill club carries over 120 fda
approved brands most brands of birth
control are free with insurance or
medicaid otherwise prices start as low
as seven dollars per month without
insurance the pill club delivers birth
control to your door for free and
discreet
packaging your neighbors won't know what
you're up to
right now when you go to the pill club
dot com slash whitney the pill club is
offering a 10 donation to bedsider.org
for every good for you listeners with
whitney cummings listener who becomes a
patient
you've heard me your donation will help
low-income individuals get access to
birth control through
bedcider.org why don't you donate one of
your baubles to them maybe i should do
it maybe you should i agree
that's thepildclub.com whitney to get
your first birth control care package
and donate to help more women in need of
affordable birth control remember the
pill club.com whitney you must use a
link to make the donation and that is
obvious and don't ask us a million
questions in the comments because i
think i said what i said and i said it
very clearly
thank you ma'am
mike you should be a queen down i
concur have you ever broken down like
forgotten to get gas in your car broke
down i did it on the way back from san
diego i had my sunglasses in front of
the gas thingy and didn't see it didn't
see it ran out of gas on the freeway
people were going 70 miles an hour i had
to pull over the side of the road and
just sit i just said what did you do
call aaa and somebody yes
two hours later so you just had to sit
in your car yes well you drive a car
that runs out of gas every 22 minutes
yeah but my dad my i ran out of gas for
the first time a week ago and my dad uh
said he's never met anyone that's run
out of gas before
well then him and i need to hang out and
he was like i am 71 years old and i've
never in my life
and he was he was shaming me so much so
now i've been going around and asking
everyone i know if they've ever run out
again i mean i was 22.
i don't need to put that into this story
it was really embarrassing when my car
broke down because um i didn't realize
what was happening like i was going
maybe 65 on the freeway and you know i
was pressing the gas and it wasn't
speeding up so i was just rolling along
and i actually rolled off the off ramp
and rolled across the street up into a
denny's parking lot and i was like
halfway up into the denny's parking lot
before the car broke down so the front
half was in the parking lot and the back
half was in the the street and
like a week ago
in the police can you imagine being a
police officer whose daughter is of
course obsessed with icarly and going
who's this insane drunk meth head that
just pulled off the road halfway into
denny's and they're like oh that's just
my daughter's hero hi
it was so weird and then two two
policemen came and they were like hey
like what's going on here
hey
so
i was just like um i was like i ran out
of gas i already called triple a they're
gonna be here in 30 40 minutes and they
were like okay they're like they're like
put it in neutral we're going to push
you up into the like you can't stay
halfway out here because people were
honking at me people were calling me so
many names what i was saying
about what you did it's just dumb it's
just not very smart bitch would have
filled up her tank
because
but people were just being so they were
so upset about it like everybody that
went around me i was just like sitting
there but you weren't obstructing the
road they just had to drive around yeah
they had to go around the that just be
insane when you're like obviously i'm
having a bad day a really bad moment i'm
having a bat you've never made a mistake
in your life
it's like i'm in trouble
right now
like why
it's just i'm in trouble you know what
i'm saying i'm a guy by miranda cosgrove
and i'm standing in a denny's parking
lot my stalkers are starting to catch up
okay someone's gonna set themselves on
fire any minute and i can't get gas in
my car i'm alone
it kind of does teach you who's nice
though like it might be a good way to
find a boyfriend to break down like that
because i noticed some people would pass
by and they'd be super nice
are you okay are you all right do you
need help and then most of the people
though weren't like that they were mad
and i was thinking this is kind of like
what if i just did it on purpose
and then i tried to figure out like who
seemed like the nicest person there was
a script written by matt herwitz and
maybe someone else but matt harris
brilliant he was on the roast we worked
together he's a genius and there was a
script that he wrote
that was about a guy who was dating a
girl that was like out of his league and
kept trying to impress her so he hired
his friend
to
play a mugger and on their date to come
mug them
so that he could fight like protect her
and protect her and like she's really
great yes
and it was it's just of course he made
it uh even more hilarious by the guy
like really started beating the shit out
of him what are you doing man like i
paid you to do that totally like he was
going too far and then he ended up
losing he was a method he was like the
idea is that i was supposed to lose he's
like yeah but i was in character i was
being a mugger like i wouldn't let you
win and he was like oh my god but yes
you could sort of just
break down on the side of the road and
be a damsel in distress and see if
people help or yell cunt
like
not date
imagine driving away going bitch and
just being like yeah that was
god i really got her
i really showed her
i did flip off a lady once while i was
driving because she like an old-school
lady not pictures
well you just flipped me off how you did
it so i can see how you please i don't
know if you want to experience it
let's go
what did you do she just came up but she
like she came up next to me and she
flipped me off because obviously i did
something i'm not sure exactly what i
did but it just it was when i first
started driving and it really caught me
off guard like i had never really been
like told off on the road before i've
probably only been driving for okay so
what happened she was like so she
flipped me off but she did it like over
and over again like when her hairs
she came up next to me and just started
like flipping me off over and over again
so then i was with my mom actually and
she was like oh like follow we should
follow her i love your mom i love your
mom i fucking love your mom if someone
cuts me off in traffic or is shitty to
me i will cancel all my meetings for the
day and i shouldn't do that because
people like you never know i'm from
appalachia what if one of those people
is a murderer and then they great they
murder you great i never hunt anyone or
do anything because it's not a thing
that if you honk at someone or like if
someone if you tell someone they have
their headlights out they might actually
be trying to kill you and it's a
it's no this is not a thing
someone told me to never um tell
somebody they have their headlights off
at night if they don't have them on
because it's a trap and that they
actually are trying to kidnap you
or they're gonna die and you could save
their life right but they might also be
kidnapping you
i feel like there's more sophisticated
and easier ways to kidnap like what like
but just all you do is flick it a bunch
of times and then they know yeah but
they save your headlights you don't stop
and park and get until now
i swear though people say that they say
never tell anyone
if i'm getting bad advice is this the
same person that told you you had gray
hair no it's a different person yeah no
don't but um by the way
you will be kidnapped at some point but
not like that it's not like that i don't
want you i don't want you thinking that
you're safe people ask for rides
sometimes and then they lead you back to
a place and they kidnap you
like they'll come up to you at the gas
station and be like hey i need a ride i
live three blocks from here could you
drive me anyway don't do that but it'll
usually seem like a really innocent no
if it's three blocks away you can walk
yeah but you knew it it's happening no
picking up hitchhikers miranda cosgrove
not a hitchhiker but like a person no
that's a hitchhiker
that not that's like ted bundy 101. did
he say his wrist was broken
put a fake cast on
yeah no that's a hard no i one time i
told a girl that was like 16 or 17 i
couldn't give her a ride three blocks
and i felt really bad at the gas station
and then she was women can be violent
too but she might have just needed to
block a ride three blocks but you know
she can also walk three blocks that's
true
she could walk three balls how old was
she probably like 17.
the only thing i don't like about that
is if she asks someone else you are the
only safe person to ask you're the only
person who would have known i was just
scared murdered her we could have driven
through drive through starbucks
and i could have dropped her off
no you're too famous for that does she
know who you are i don't think so
can you tell right away if someone is
like i know you and i'm acting
differently because it's you no i really
can't do you feel like you can like if
somebody knows who i know right away
really yes i guess sometimes i do like
if it's obvious but sometimes someone
um
like on a plane or whatever
tries really hard to treat me like a
normal person
or says things like yeah i don't really
watch com like i'm like oh no you know
you're def you're pretending giving you
a hard yeah
i'm saying yeah i appreciate the people
that are just like
what is it i'm sorry i do know you but i
do i like i just appreciate whatever is
honest if you don't recognize me at all
totally fine love that i'll probably
want to talk your ear off because i get
really excited when i can talk to
someone who's not like so what's it like
like
you know how did you get into comedy
it's like dude there's about 42 podcasts
you can listen to if you want to know
the answer to that like why do i have to
do this on a plane not monetized um but
i get excited when someone that like
clearly has no idea who i am because i
can just be like pretend i'm like a
pharmaceutical sales rep yeah it's like
going to a new school with a new
identity something like you could just
make up
have you thought about doing that
that came to your mind like real fast
but like people i know it's like
like faking your death and moving to new
mexico and just like shaving your head
and over
just getting a bunch of like plastic
surgery to look like a different person
just like going to the witness
protection program starting fresh
and hitchhiking there
i'm obsessed with you hold on i know we
have to get back on these questions uh
okay
other skin pro you okay don't wash your
face don't wash your face wear a lot of
sun sleep in your makeup buy some oil
that you talked about on something what
oil
um i've tried a bunch of different ones
i can't i don't even know if i have like
a
consistent one favorite okay um just oil
i mean by the way grape seed oil from a
whole foods or amazon
tastes like a straight-up grapeseed oil
it's like three dollars like that's what
i use to wash my face and uh when i go
into the shower i put well before i go
to the shower i put grapeseed oil all
over my body and face and then shower
and exfoliate and stuff that's cool i
never even knew that i've only ever put
it on my face yeah you can i should do
like yeah neck neck but always upward
motions always upward motions i don't
know if i do upward motions
what are the upward motions to do the
upper body because if you do your skin
is a rubber band if you pull down it's
just gonna pull when i see people doing
their makeup where they're just like you
know putting the dragging their hands
down their face
don't do that like i put concealer on
and i just imagine how young you'd look
if you had been doing upward motions you
would look like a zygote actually keep
doing that wait wait
i just had the first thought of
sabotaging you the best way to apply oil
is to press really hard down down on
your face down and hold do you use jade
rollers ever mm-hmm no is that not a
good it's not a thing it isn't but it
feels good when it's cold
it feels good if it's cold it would be
good for any kind of inflammation like
puffy i mean if i have puffy under eyes
i just take two soda cans and just put
them on them
makeup artist she knows anytime she's
doing my makeup i have two soda cans on
my face and then um it could help with
like lymphatic drainage a little bit if
you know the spots to do it like under
here and stuff which that just it
doesn't it's not that the jade roller is
changing your skin it's just that it's
activating the lymphatic drainage and
then fluids start to drain so then your
face gets a little more
you're holding less water basically it's
like water you're you're essentially
massaging it for like water water yeah
so it's like if you have those know what
where your lymphatic spots are to
trigger that okay i think it's like here
under your um
neck here here maybe right here or
something i don't know i i did that for
a while and then i was just like i have
too many things to to do apply and too
many tools to mess around to play around
with the only tool i fuck with is the um
derma roller which are the little tiny
um
pincushion roller on your face because a
lot of our product doesn't even get
absorbed into our skin oh does it make
little little tiny punctures tiny tiny
tiny bleed
you do not believe no no no and you
might because you're you and you because
i know you trip and fall the second you
use it and it will go into your ocular
nerve and now icarly season two of the
reboot you're a pirate
we now take a jarring pause in our
program uh
look i mean i know we love miranda
cosgrove but it's enough already with
the yapping right we're gonna show you
some footage of a very sp there's a
visitor
lurking around my domicile i have a lot
of animals in my backyard a lot of
creatures a lot of flora a lot of fauna
but it's kind of getting out of control
you know i mean i i can get nature
lovers out there exploring i don't know
i've just been hearing a lot of
screaming going on what's going on out
there another surprise guest so many in
one day
yeah
you bet you bet your bottom dollar i
will i did but we can't go out there
otherwise i mean i'd have to put on this
native sunscreen before we go out there
so i figured we'd just show you the
video of it great right because i'm not
letting you borrow i'm ready sunscreen
okay let's
uh hit it
quacky hi earl i'm back from the dead to
explore the good for you lands and i got
to thinking much like the droppings of
the vaquita life sometimes stinks
luckily we don't have to thanks to
native and their incredible products
such as the legendary aluminium-free
deodorant
body wash and toothpaste
but it doesn't stop there they also
invented a sunscreen crikey because they
want us to enjoy the great outdoors and
all it has to offer
while staying safe from the sun's
harmful ways and take it from me you'll
want to stay away from harmful rays
like you love this
[Music]
well that was
incredible a lot to promise amazing i'm
flabbergasted i am that was some
skullduggery if i've ever seen some
real tomfoolery but i did
glean a lot from that video
yeah i want to stay fresh i want to stay
clean a lot of celebrities right now are
talking about how they don't shower
that's we don't do that over here that's
not us we stay fresh we stay clean we
wash our legs we wash our backs we watch
in between our toes with native shower
gel native deo.com
whitney or use promo code whitney at
checkout and get 20 off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
emily stop doing that
uh deo.com slash whitney or use promo
code whitney at checkout for 20
off your first order look at those two
lovebirds you think that benton and
emily could be that close if they
weren't using native deodorant and body
wash we're super glued to the hip and
look at their look at those sunscreen
faces look they look like um baby
vampires only with native
hey girly hey hi um are you interested
in an exciting business opportunity with
great potential
yeah do you want to be your own boss do
you want to sell products make money and
have your friends also make money that
sounds great i know
but i feel like i we i am the boss here
already help help help okay
what's this oh my god i don't like this
oh cracking oh god i've been stung by a
stingway again
someone called to talk to him oh my god
guys call a doctor attention hong kong
call
her okay
hey hold on i'm sorry well what do you
what's your do you have an insurance
plan no
okay goodness sake i don't have i'm
coming i'm dying okay i got it i got it
i'm calling it
i don't think i can hold on hello hi
hi yeah i need to make an appointment
with the doctor right away yes big
emergency oh i got it oh you don't take
insurance oh
okay well no big no big deal it's fine
i'll come back later okay
is there like a waitlist or something i
could get him in it looks pretty sweet
wait wait wait wait wait no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no they can get me no i don't
want to know they can get me in there we
can use
everybody help i'm losing too much blood
wait wait no we can use that jock
we can use zock dock just download the
zocdoc app it's the easiest way to find
a great doctor instantly and book an
appointment
[Music]
could you do that
with zocdoc you can search for local
doctors who can take your insurance read
verified reviews and book an appointment
in person or video chat never wait on
hold with your receptionist again so we
shouldn't just pull it out no no i just
feel like we could
not have a cuticle no steve's right
whether you need a primary care
physician a dentist a dermatologist a
psychiatrist eye doctor other specialist
sock doc's got you covered go to zoc doc
dot com slash whitney and download the
zoc doc app to sign up for free listen
every month millions of people use sock
doc take it from this clock doc
do it for nothing else to not get blood
all over your carpet sounds like zocdoc
makes healthcare easy now is the time to
prioritize your health go to
zocdoc.com
whitney and download the zoc doc app for
free and book a top rated doctor
many are available as soon as today
that's zoc doc dot
well don't say slash right now i can
spend my life in this sweet surrender
because every moment
are you ready this is a great segue i
suffered from low sex drive for a full
year whether or not benton singing that
song to you
could possibly be the cause of it i
don't know having a low sex drive is
very distressing it's how you connect
with your partner it's how you normally
de-stress having sex is relaxing when
you lose your sex drive
i started to panic i was like worried i
was like am i broken is something wrong
with me
were you not trying hard enough
i did everything mountain i watched
legends of the fall in slow motion the
julia armond scene where she cheats that
used to do it every time no longer i
listen to baby face
i watch nigella lawson cook bacon with
coca-cola still nothing the things that
normally would have turned me on didn't
that is a problem
that is a problem addie or flib
answering god it makes me feel smart to
say the like pharmaceutical name flib
answerin is the fda approved little pink
pill for certain pre-menopausal women
bothered by low sex drive visit
a-d-d-y-i
dot com slash whitney and complete your
online consultation to see if addie is
right for you adi is for pre-menopausal
women with acquired generalized
hypoactive
or low sexual desire disorder which is
also called h
hsdd
who have not had problems with low
sexual desire in the past who have low
sexual desire no matter what type of
sexual activity the situation or the
sexual partner the low sexual desire is
troubling to them and is not due to a
medical or mental health problem
problems in the relationship or medicine
or other drug use a-d-d-y-i
is not for use in men or to enhance
sexual performance your risk of severe
low blood pressure and fainting is
increased if you drink one to two
standard alcoholic drinks close
in the time to your addy dose wait at
least two hours after drinking before
taking addie at bedtime
your risk of severe low blood pressure
and fainting is also increased if you
take a certain prescription
over the counter or herbal medications
or have liver problems low blood
pressure and fainting can happen when
you take addie even if you don't drink
alcohol or take other medicines
sleepiness sometimes serious can occur
common side effects include dizziness
nausea tiredness difficulty falling
asleep or staying asleep and dry mouth
see full pi including boxed warning at
addie a-d-d-y-i
dot com slash p-i
or call eight four four
pink
pill that's eight four four pink pill
visit addie dot com slash whitney that's
a d d y i dot com
slash whitney
what is your
i don't know some of these are a little
bit how was she
approached to revive icarly and was
there pushback to make it adulty
um they definitely at first wanted the
show to be for kids still
um but i called jerry trainor the taller
guy on
the show with me and he um he was like
we he we both kind of thought it was a
really good idea to make it for adults
instead because we both were kind of
scared to go back and do a show for kids
as adults yeah um and we felt like we
weren't going to be able to do like more
interesting storylines
he's like please don't
get me time's up but it didn't really
like come to us right away we were kind
of both just like this
we don't want to ruin it we don't want
to redo something we did before not as
well um
and then when the idea came up that
maybe it could be for adults everything
kind of opened up and changed it like it
just made the whole thing seem more like
it could really be fun right right and
not like you're pretending and having to
do like a corny version like this like
pretend you're little again don't feel
honest yeah so it's been cool it's been
really fun getting to do it and getting
to play the characters um aged up
because the storylines are things we
would have never i mean you look at the
same age but anyway
does uh do you get a say in the hot guys
that come on the show to play your love
interest i do i do
i do get to say i didn't before when i
was younger when i was on the show but
now um i get to help with the casting
process so i do okay well
good to know i like the person who asked
that question they're just thinking like
what would be the most fun thing about
being on this show
is there something really
cravingly satisfying about going through
audition tapes of like
50 gorgeous guys and be like no not hot
enough not like if only
it makes me feel like a male hollywood
producer from the 80s did you get to
help pick guys on your show of course
yes
yeah and then on two board girls that
was always like but we always wanted to
go like cool like eric andre played kat
denning's love interest for a super long
you know it's like there
is usually pressure from the network to
hire these like cartoon superman
impersonator type guys like that just
look like they've walked out of a museum
but i like to do kind of cooler more
offbeat types
there was this guy that came up and um i
thought he was really cute in the
audition tape and then um the day after
he came to set to start rehearsing and
stuff i went on his instagram and i was
looking at it and he was engaged to his
high school sweetheart and i went back
like two years on his instagram and he
was like the nicest person they met when
they were like 14. they just it was just
like a whole great job on making that
fake ig profile to get hired on icarly
he's smart he just seemed like an angel
profile yeah he was on the show which
one was he um he's not in an episode yet
it's one of the later episodes in the
season oh god it's just not out yet um
i questions from your ig fans uh
boop dog noses
do i boop dog
there's not even a do i
[Laughter]
what's on your bucket list i actually
like this oh on my bucket list things
you i'd like to someday get married is
that something to put on a bucket list
okay no never mind take that out
um no you should get married okay if
it's the right person
get married let's say get married to the
right
to the right person and the equal and
someone that deserves you it's gonna be
hard to find someone that deserves you
okay i'm gonna but you will um what else
is i mean i have i have skin in this
game i will be officiating this wedding
so
um what else could be on my bucket list
getting married like having a farm
having a farm would be awesome i'll go
have these with you on that i would love
a farm
um you kind of have a farm don't you
well you have horses kind of yeah um ish
content farm
uh what about um like destinations you
want to travel to countries cities girls
my friend my childhood best friend moved
to ireland and just had twins a couple
days ago
i've never been to ireland before so i
want to go i will go with you i want to
go visit her have you been before no i'm
dying to go everybody says ireland's
amazing you know that ireland doesn't
have snakes really gosh it seems like it
would have because it's an island
that's so the phoenix never got there
they've never met
no they never made it so they don't have
to worry someone would have brought them
should we bring the snakes
smuggle some snakes and diarrhea we
bring in a way bag full of snakes to
ireland i've bungee jumped before
have you ever done that no i've only
done it once i did it in fresno at a
fair and that is very scary on the list
of life-threatening things you have
mentioned that is what is the worst
crazy thing
i did it for a guy because i was like 14
or 15 and i um went to the fair with him
and he was like oh it'd be so fun like
we could do it together because they'll
either let you do it by yourself or you
can like hold on to something how much
was the how long was the jump i don't
remember but it felt insane it felt and
you know you have to sign a thing saying
it's okay if you if i die
yeah yeah yeah and it just looked so
it's like going to a like a carnival or
you know how the rides are really scary
and rickety yeah it was like that kind
of thing like you walked down the city
and stepped up to the top
there from another city they were driven
there in a subaru outback from the last
place the fair was set up
it was intense and you can decide if you
want to go backwards or if you want to
go forward it's actually easier to go
backwards than forward
why easier how because it's supposed to
be if you're really scared to do it it's
better to just close your eyes and fall
back but if you're really scared to do
it just don't you don't have to do it
unless you're trying to impress the guy
that you think is cute
this would be so cool i broke my
shoulder snowboarding to try to impress
the guy so i will not throw stones why
did you pretend that you could snowboard
when you hadn't before or you just fell
back he
snowboarded big diamonds black diamonds
or whatever and
he would like snowboard with other
people and i was like he's having this
experience without me like i want to be
a part of it it's a big part of his life
and his son's life and i'm gonna learn
how to snowboard and i had tried to
learn for another boyfriend five years
prior
so i did have a little bit of you were
trying to like nail it like actually
like go down there
so i i met with an instructor for
like 40 minutes and i was like i got it
i was weirdly i'm like i got it right i
either get something or i don't and i
was like i got skiing no bueno will not
happen can't do it because i get too
distracted and angry by me going down
like trying to go down like really
slowly and then a four-year-old will
just whiz
you and you're like you're like
like tiny people flying by you and i'm
like like i'm quit i'm taking my toys
and i'm going home and i also don't like
the uh barrier to entry of skiing and
snowboarding it's like three grand just
to
spend three grand
it's like all the shit you have to buy
and the boot it's like oh in order to
even get out there yeah i've never been
snowboarding it's like most jackets
winter jackets or 200 snowboarding
jackets that are when the same thing are
700. this is there for snowboarding i
will not i shan't did you have all the
cute stuff though for the guy for the
snowboarding the cutest how did you buy
the best it was so cute and so tight and
so well fitted that once i shattered my
shoulder they had to cut it off really
so i spent all this money on these like
cute like snow bunny outfits that were
so snug and fit and have all these like
designs but then once i broke my
shoulder you can't lift your arm so they
just had to cut it off me and i was like
oh man i just paid for this that sleeve
was like 500 bucks
so i
went up to the black diamond with him
and then i was going and the whole thing
about snore it's so mental you can't be
a second ahead or a second behind
mentally and then the instructor said
something that i love and to this day
it's a refrain in the back of my head in
terms of like what i focus on is gonna
either is gonna happen so if i'm like i
don't want this to happen you're still
focusing on it and you're putting your
energy there and you're manifesting it
so he would always say you go where you
look so if you're wanna go this way you
have to look this way and visualize
yourself going there you go where you
look so if if i need to go this
direction and i look forward because i'm
trying to get someone's approval or
check in with someone else you're just
gonna fall that's where you're gonna go
so i was getting it i was doing my
little turns and my little swivels and
he like yelled something and i was like
oh i need to respond to that because i
don't want him to think we're not soul
mates and i was like huh and just
shattered my entire shoulder you just
fell down right on it i fell straight
forward hit the snow
and shattered my shoulder and then i
went to
the doctor four days later
because i was like that's fine like i
don't i have a high pretty high
tolerance for pain and then finally i
just i couldn't lift my arm i was like
this is weird and someone's like you
need to go to a doctor
and um
i went to the doctor and the doctor was
like this injury makes no sense if you
fell straight down on your face you
should have hit your face and either
broke your nose got a concussion like
people with this exact injury this
happens all the time they damage their
face they get broken necks concussions
and like
very bad and then he was like so were
you wearing like a protective vest or
like what was going on and i was like oh
i do have fake tits and he's like oh
good so they basically saved you for you
saved your life oh it like patted your
phone yes my tits i
the tits hit the ice and so my head is
yeah they didn't hurt the ice before yes
i kind of bounced off my tits
that's so weird to be figuring out with
a doctor
yeah because i said i was like i was
like a vest i was like no i do i mean i
do have like c cup uh tits he's like oh
that's it
that's the answer i was like does this
happen a lot i've never heard of
somebody's boobs saving them save my
life
they might be leaking inside me right
now killing me but in that moment they
did save money did your shoulder heal
pretty fast no i had to do eight months
of physical therapy
for people not watching you're not gonna
this isn't gonna make any sense but for
like 20 minutes a day i'd have to just
like do this with a pen why does it help
you it's like you have to basil yeah you
have to well because there was like a
tear and a fracture and you don't want
it to freeze that way so basically like
if you don't do this physical therapy
your shoulder will freeze that way right
and you will be an ogre so you have to
do the most boring exercises you just
have to do this you have to do this you
have to stand up
lean over move your
arm without using the muscle to rotate
it
yes you're doing it you're doing it yes
i hope you don't give hand drops like
that
um i'm trying to put the pieces together
of what's going on
in your romantic life but like is there
any like language you want to learn or
skill you want to try or like um i'd
love to be able to speak spanish i took
french in school which i regret i wish i
would have taken spanish i don't
remember any of the french at all
absolutely none um i can't really do any
sports or anything it'd be great to
maybe i should try snowboarding and see
where it goes
don't give that a shot don't do that
you're too accident prone when you're
not on a slippery thing on ice but i
feel like we should schedule a girls
trip i feel like we're long overdue i
want to go to machu picchu i think we
should go to florida to stay at amanda
cerny's oh i know i want to go to amazon
visit so we should do that because i'm
on tour in the fall and i have a bunch
of dates kind of like near her so i feel
like we should all do that and she got
another dalmatian oh i know so cute why
she's cruella de vil at this point i
mean she's hoarding dalmatians okay i
know we have to i know we have to go
faster uh how the fuck is her hair so
shiny
these questions are just like super nice
compliments like it's not they're angry
compliments
your hair is makes people angry you have
to you can't say conditioning it um i do
condition it a lot good keep doing what
you're doing whoever told you that is a
hater that's like whoever that is is the
selena's aunt and you're like coconut
oil in my hair a lot have you ever done
it yes put it just on the ends like that
or like i'll wash my hair put a bunch of
coconut oil on it and then just put it
up in a bun on my head and leave it
there all day yes yes and then it feels
way more hydrated the next day yes and
you can get it for like five bucks on a
genius yes
i mean this humidity is kind of a juicy
i've been very curious uh to see what
you smell like by 4 p.m
um
uh how do people react when they see you
in public
weirdest encounter we kind of cover that
a little bit people um on the show i was
on when i was little when i was eight or
nine i always called people boobs that
was my um like little one-liner thing i
always said and my catchphrase so people
come up to me a lot um sometimes like
cute guys will come up to me and be like
hey um can you call me a boob
so annoying i know i people come up to
me and they're like will you roast me
and i'm like
i'll change the way you perceive
yourself forever you don't want this
i'm just like sure like
like and they're like thanks
like was that experience everything you
wanted to be
i mean it's like can we just take a
photo like i mean
why they'll be like they want to like
film
me calling them a boat yeah okay well
that makes more sense yeah it's just
it's just such a weird thing to carry
from the time you're like eight or nine
but it is fun choose your catchphrase
wisely
it will haunt you for the rest of your
life if any eight or nine-year-old child
actors are listening to this be careful
what that catchphrase is in my first
special i did a joke which i'm not
saying i stand by it it is a good
observation but i i had a joke about
balls and i said something i was like
why do all balls look like they're a
hundred years old
and it was sort of about like how balls
are you know so
they're just so old like immediately
they're so like benjamin bunny and uh i
will be walking to the airport and be
like why do i ball and i'm like and i
always forget the joke because it was 10
years ago i was like my balls look a
hundred years old my you just look
forward to it like someone's being
really weird sorry i am getting in line
it's southwest i wasn't prepared for
that hippocampus tickle
um okay i have pitches for the next
icarly season oh cool i'm excited for
that um
she hires an employee
and oh i i have it i have it uh many
lawyers have this in writing as well she
hires an employee and they tell her
she's not creating a safe space
like an assistant yeah like hiring an
employee and then you have to deal with
all the sort of stuff that comes walking
on eggshells because i love the idea of
the next generation the 22 year olds
they you're old
and you don't get it and you're ignorant
and you're
uh toxic by accident just your your
varies and you'll never understand and
you don't get it so just the idea that
you're so young and there's someone
younger than you coming in well this
isn't toxic telling you what's good and
what's bad yeah exactly just sort of
like how your behavior is like toxic
because it would be funny to see that
character with an assistant because yes
it just seems funny like out of
character and also just like how like
what i love about their dynamic is how
wildly inappropriate they are and how i
love the relationship with your best
friend uh the stylist and how you the
episode where you guys were fighting and
you went to the event together and were
walking down the red carpet with the
dress that wasn't stitched it's like so
funny so lucille ball i can't believe
you totally actually watched thanks
of course
i mean i watched the entire
thing
that's amazing i'm a fan of icarus
i didn't want this to happen this might
have been my plan all along this was
weird because like when you meet someone
you become friends with them and they're
famous it's like i don't want to be a
fan of them that'll toxify it you know
but i was like i have to be good at this
interview so i'm going to watch it and i
was like we were me and alex your future
husband were having a blast and i was
like so in love with youtube's chemistry
too but the idea of a new person coming
in and being you two fighting about
something and being like you can't yell
at a black woman like that
like she's queer like what do you like
just the idea of or all the
inappropriate jokes that happen she's
like this that's an inappropriate joke
and that's punching down where it's just
like you know so i just that happens and
would just be great tension and great
conflict that would be good to have to
walk on eggshells around her
um there oh oh
oh
oh yeah you struggle to be a boss and
you start you become her assistant
inevitably oh yeah yeah do you need some
cars doing everything
yeah because you're like so nice you're
like do you need some coffee do you know
what are you good i bet that would
happen if i hadn't
she's like i think i'm gonna have lunch
or like i got it what do you want i go
like she's running she's like um
gluten-free tacos where and you're like
running or trying to nine groceries
trying to get it all right
like i love it when you become your
assistant's assistant the idea because
you're so afraid that they're gonna
think you're rude about you or call you
toxic
so you're like i have this monster in
the other room who could tweet about me
at any time
i gotta make her keep thank god keep her
happy okay and um uh uh
yeah because one tweet one accusation
like that whether it's true or false
it's out there
it's out there and some people believe
it no matter what yeah but it will be
circulated even if it's not true and
just the idea of being terrified of
someone thinking you're a bad person
when you're an amazing person i thought
it'd be funny if carly was cancelled in
one of the episodes
you have to do that
you have to do that it'd be good for an
episode because that's just such a
powerful because there's also like real
underpin like emotional pathos and
underpinning of the show and just the
idea of like you can get cancelled and
move forward it's like it's just the new
haters bullet anyone that cancels you
for an old tweet they didn't like you to
begin with
you know what i'm saying or they're just
so sad in their lives that they need to
watch someone fall just to be able to
feel less bad about you like we i have
compassion for those people the people
that are like this person's it's just
like
i hope that worked
i hope that throwing a stone at someone
else like made you feel better you know
that's what i used to do when i was
jealous of other people and just wanted
what they had i was like well they're
not funny
yeah they are that's why i'm saying that
i'm mad at the fact that they're funny
and i'm looking for a reason uh or some
way to feel better about myself i'm
self-soothing by being judgmental
self-righteous indignation jealousy
gossiping negativity yeah i feel like
that when i watch reality shows
sometimes like especially if it's a
reality show where somebody's having
like a terrible time
i'm glad that you brought that up that
brings me to my next pitch
um which is that um
she gets in oh she gets an offer to do a
paid partnership with chick-fil-a
but it's very specific it's a
problematic company that right now it's
like oh the owner of it is in a super
pac that is anti-lgbtq whatever but the
little sister needs money to go on a
nice field trip
uh
is learning french maybe not french
and the class is doing a trip to
montreal that's 10 years like she needs
to help pay for some trip for her
so we have to get him
away because it's a bunch of money yeah
exactly and it's like some kind of
problematic company and the idea for me
is always like when a problematic
company or toxic company comes to me my
thing is always like okay
maybe the most punk rock shit i can do
is not pass on this it's to take your
money and do something good with it
you know so it's like when uh like when
i get offers to do cosmetic campaigns
with companies that don't do that don't
um that test on animals i'll normally
say i'm passing on this because you test
on like i'll be very clear about it
clear about it yeah and even if they
don't test on animals uh in america
oftentimes they they are required to to
sell in china which is their biggest
market because that's part of their
rules they're required to test on
animals in order to sell it there yes i
didn't know that yes it sucks drives me
nuts and so um yeah the most gangster
shit like a cosmetic company can do is
say we're not gonna sell in china
because we would have to but they're
that's tricky because that's how they're
gonna be the most lucrative you know so
um but just the idea of well if i don't
take this money
a toxic asshole is gonna take this money
and they're just going to use it to
whatever buy hookers and
what i don't know donate to them buy
hookers maybe you could use it for
animals
that's what i'm saying so my new thing
is like okay let me
kind of educate them and pay it forward
yes let me take their money
so that they don't give it to some
dickhead who's not going to do something
good with it donate it and then be clear
with them like this is what i did with
your money and i will never
uh work with you again or support you if
you don't stop testing on animals and
i'm a squeaky wheel
and you don't want me as your enemy
that's cool that's a good way of um
switching it around and getting
just the idea of like having to deal
with that as a woman like because it's
also like
making that kind of money as a woman
this is a win this is revolutionary any
you know so it's like the idea of you
saying like i can't work with this
company because they do bad things or
they you know don't pay their workers or
whatever and then you do the partnership
you take it and then you send all the
workers the money you know turn it
around yeah like i like to do that shit
it's like yeah you just paid we just
figured out a way to get your employees
paid it's a loophole yeah kind of thing
so i don't know i think that's like just
an interesting moral dilemma that a lot
of younger people are dealing with right
now probably a lot of people that are
influencers too get all sorts of crazy
offers all the time and where you're
like kind of in an ethical dilemma where
you're like i grew up poor this could go
away any minute i'm getting offered
thirty thousand dollars like how can i
pass on this yeah and just figuring out
a way so that it's not so black and
white
uh that we go okay maybe i can take
money from this craving organization and
use it for good because that's the only
way this organization is going to do
anything good yeah you can stay true to
yourself but still let me use their
money against them
you know i'm saying yeah um uh also
okay she's pressured to do a video
collab with a famous youtube star but
kind of tacky and notorious influencer
who's batshit crazy i'm available
uh like the female like logan paul
um he actually i say jake paul i think
logan paul i'm kind of i like his new
glow up um
and
uh oh and then carly does it they do the
video together but it's for the youtube
channel and and carly and she's like a
judgy monster she's like not good like
super shallow rude disrespectful and
that in her uh youtube video carly gets
the villain cut
oh it makes her look look terrible makes
her look terrible like the other girl
looked like she's the nice person yeah
so it's like like carlos being so nice
and patient and like something happened
where um you know one of your friends
came in and you're like get out of here
and you know we're shooting and then she
cuts it like you're like saying it to
her you know like you guys are early why
are you here i'm doing something and she
uses it twists the whole time to make it
seem like you're a monster because like
so much of that is like when you look on
reality tv shoes shows shoes um you're
like new business uh you look at it and
you're like okay they use that same
reaction four times the one to and i've
been on these shows where it's uh they
make you look totally different than
however you ask well they have you
they'll have an audience okay so the
cameras will be on you if you're in the
audience on someone's show like a game
show or a talent show or whatever and um
not your show you're just coming to be
supportive in the audience they'll have
an audience warm-up person come out and
be like
hey guys i just had a pizza for lunch
and it was covered in mold and you go
okay ew and then they'll use that
reaction when talent comes out such a
trick it's such a trick and i've gone
and then they'll they'll do things that
they're like making you laugh making you
clap so they know exactly what they're
doing they know exactly what they're
doing so there's maybe she's like very
weird with you and is very like drink
this drink and you're like
and she just uses that as a response to
something that she said yes like she's
trying to
fix her reputation by making someone
super kind with a great reputation look
toxic or something they're being mean
yeah like carly was mean to me yeah that
sounds good
um watch me steal all these ideas i'm
you're not telling them i'm literally
pitching them to you i'm literally
pitching them to you
i love you i carly
you i don't have to tell you you guys
have all seen it promoting it seems a
little ridiculous
season two
you're the best thanks for having me
back it's always a blast to hang out
with you
i love you and don't ride elephants
[Music]